[Music]
men act kind of kooky around you I
completely understand it but they do you
were very mesmerizing presence and I'm
betting that your experiences that men
act kind of silly and dopey around you
is that is that true I don't I don't
think so I just I don't know no I'm just
thinking you seem like someone if you
were like walking down the street you
know that people would guys would just
not be paying attention to what they
were doing do you know anything that's
the sense I get that's what I would be
doing if I saw you walking down the
street I didn't know you I would I would
I would lose my mind a little bit I had
one I had one incident but this was
years ago I am I had it was summer and I
just gone out and bought this little
wispy white summer dress and I was going
to meet my friends are you cheering
friendship or wispy white dress the
wispy white dresses I think that you
know any girl and a wispy white dress
but I was going to meet my friends at a
British pub here and my friend Louis was
waiting for me outside and this guy was
riding a bike by and he started staring
at me and Louis was watching it from a
distance and he said the whole thing
went in slow-mo and the guy just hit the
kerb and flew off his bike no I think
that's the one you saw I think you're
not paying attention I think your whole
life is you walking down the street and
people driving by in
being very nice I know what I like many
actors change their hair color if
they're if they have red hair or their
famous revelation then they change their
hair color and I always feel abandoned
that was feel I do I feel angry at them
like why there are so few of us don't
leave us don't leave us
I'm so happy that you've stuck you look
absolutely gorgeous but you've stuck
with the wings yeah you know I I have
been this color now probably 20 years
and I was actually thinking at the end
of Mad Men maybe going a little bit
blonder actually more sort of like you
are now still red still right I'm not
leaving I would never I mean no no no no
you made it quite clear the minute
you're done with your character on Mad
Men you're gonna go blonde that's what
you just told me I could see you see my
eyes well up no I would I would always
say strawberry I just you know I've been
I've sort of attached this sort of look
now with Joan and we're ending and I
feel like I I sort of want to separate
myself and have a little goodbye but I'm
still probably just take a picture of
you into my hair colorist and say make
you know give me Conan's hair that would
be the dumbest thing you could ever do I
haven't Christina Hendricks fame for my
beauty make me look like
beautiful strawberry blood yeah you know
you also have not to embarrass you but
you'd have to have such gorgeous you're
I'm very pale but you're luminous you
know you're you're pale in a beautiful
way I'm pale in that way where people
say are you getting enough iron Wow you
are being so nice to me you know a
little makeup helps like it you know I
hose me down and it doesn't
nothing changes my little cream blush a
little they've tried everything they've
tried painting veins in my cheek that
probably won't work no that's horribly